Iran on Sunday issued its first known
death sentence it's connected to the
government's Crackdown on what is now
more than two months of anti-regime
demonstrations
the death sentence is itself not facing
a death of its own according to Amnesty
International more than two-thirds of
countries in the world have abolished
the death penalty in law or at least in
practice that means that they have not
executed anyone for at least 10 years
but 55 countries still use the death
penalty often these are countries that
are considered to have flawed or unfair
Justice systems China is estimated to be
the world's leading executioner it is
followed by Iran Egypt Saudi Arabia and
Syria globally amnesty found at least
579 people were put to death by
governments last year that is not
including the estimated thousands who
were executed in China from where
there's a lack of course of official
data and information
well for the next three days politicians
and activists from around the world they
are meeting for the World Congress
against the death penalty right here in
Berlin one of those is here with me at
the big table tonight John Bessler he's
a professor of law at the University of
Baltimore and at Georgetown University
in the U.S he is also author of the book
The Death penalty's denial of
fundamental human rights
and Professor we are glad to have you
with us tonight I just wanted to ask you
you are from the United States a country
where the death penalty is legal where
the death penalty is carried out still I
mean that club as we just heard includes
countries such as China Saudi Arabia
Iran Egypt what's it like being an
American law professor at a World
Congress dedicated to abolishing the
death penalty yeah I've been working on
this issue of about 30 years actually
and this is the eighth World Congress
actually in Berlin these are held
periodically and the both the the German
Justice Minister and the and the German
foreign minister spoke out against the
death penalty and and in one case
described how it's really inconsistent
with the Democrat democracy uh and if we
look at the the kinds of countries that
are using the death penalty regularly
you see China Iran Iraq North Korea and
and the US just shouldn't belong in that
list and so I think we need to start
thinking about the death penalty not
through the frames of some sort of Crime
Control but through the the clearly the
lens of of Human Rights which is now
where squarely Europe is yeah I'm going
to pick up on that you you've argued
that human rights as outlined in the
1948 Universal Declaration of Human
Rights cannot be truly Universal as long
as there are countries with the death
penalty talk me through that why do you
think that you are connected yeah
absolutely so the the universal
Declaration of Human Rights outlawed
torture and says no one shall be
subjected to torture or cruel inhuman or
degrading treatment or punishment and if
you think about what the death penalty
actually is the death penalty really
just constitutes a series of death
threats if you think about Capital
charge it's on a piece of paper but it's
really a death threat a death sentence
is just a more credible death threat and
then ultimately as you approach uh the
actual execution
um it it again that instills that fear
of death and a mock execution a
simulated execution is already
considered a classic example of
psychological torture so in Germany they
put in the constitution in 1949 that
definitely is abolished and and in the
Geneva Convention the third genomic
convention we see a Prohibition against
both physical and mental torture but in
the United States we've not focused
sufficiently on the on the concept of
mental torture that idea that uh simply
subjecting someone to a threat of death
is itself torturous we've heard that
from um American not only attorneys but
professors such as yourself that when
people are on death row just the fact
that they know that their death is
imminent and they can't do anything to
change it that in itself is tantamount
to torture right and the European case
law actually establishes that there's a
case called soaring which says that
there's something called the death row
phenomenon and that means that there's
not extraditions going on to the United
States from actually not just Europe but
other places around the world and
actually that squares up with uh with
the provision uh against the convention
Against torture which says you should
not return someone to a place where they
might be subjected to torture so that's
kind of the the I think the main
argument to think about is that think of
it through a different lens because the
states that actually carry out the death
penalty actually have higher violent
crime rates than those that on average
that that don't have the death penalty
well let me let me pick up on this this
notion of a violent crime politicians in
the United States have argued now for
decades that the death penalty is a
deterrent in this last midterm election
that we saw one of the main issues is
the increase in violent crime in the
United States I mean how do you explain
this that we're not seeing the death
penalty deterring murders for example
right I mean I what I'd like to say is
that you know crime is about what the
offenders do and obviously people have a
right to be concerned about crime they
should be concerned about crime
absolutely but the punishment is about
what we're going to do in response to
the crime what we're going to how we're
going to act uh and so if you think
about it that way you need to start
thinking about how we're behaving and so
for example non-lethal Corporal
punishments have long been put aside
things like whipping prisoners in the
old days they used to subject people to
the pillory and stocks those things are
no longer allowed and so what we're
seeing is countries around the world are
moving against the death penalties you
noted South Africa's uh constitutional
Court of South Africa actually declared
the death penalty unconstitutional back
in the mid 90s so the Supreme Court
which actually once did declare the
death penalty unconstitutional in 1972
that's right and then reverse course
maybe they had it right in 1972. well we
know that they do also now have a track
record of changing their minds when it
comes to important Court decisions
professor John besser we appreciate you
coming into talking with us tonight
thank you thank you